ich bin schon immer als kalender
wahnsinn aber es ist krieg also ich muss
sagen heute auf diesen adventskalender
freue ich mich aus irgendeinem grund
besonders doll wurde jetzt gar nicht so
großartig besonders ist ich bin ja nun
aus dem alter relativ raus meine
finanziellen möglichkeiten aus
taschengeld bestehen also ich hab nie
taschengeld bekommen aber ich habe
gearbeitet und das war halt babysitter
jobs und so das war also bekomme ja so
30 bis 40 euro im monat habe ich
verdient und dann kann man sich
natürlich nicht wenn die beauty und was
auch immer leisten sondern greift halt
zu der jugendlichen drogeriemarkt das
sind es tut mir leid
hintergrundgeräusche hat in meiner
straße wird gebaut und das wird jetzt
noch die nächsten monate so weitergehen
noch ein besonders vergesse
dieses videos nicht gespannt ist alle
diese videos lichtgestalt der bands
kalender gekostet ich hab schon
vergessen 22 eur 95 na ja gut das heißt
ungefähr 1 euro pro türchen können wir
rechnen wir hoffen natürlich mehr ich
finde es ist eine tolle marke in
erinnerung sind nicht negativ daran es
sind natürlich nicht high quality
produkte aber ja
für die jüngere zielgruppe fürs üben
fürs erste erfahrungen machen finde ich
sehr gut jetzt wo wir den preis wissen
können wir mal was äußere sprechen ich
finde diesen adventskalender der macht
mir richtig lust auf weihnachten ich
finde der sieht richtig festlich aus
einen tannenbaum eine winterliche stadt
ein karussell der weihnachtsmann sollen
schnell vergessen haben for access also
dieses ex-miss bleiben wir
wahrscheinlich alle hoch oben
es wäre so komisch wenn man dieses jahr
einfach an weihnachten überlegen muss ob
man seine familie besuchen sie nicht
anstecken will ich rede jetzt nicht
lange um ihn wir wollen wissen was da
drin ist türchen nummer eins tolles also
ja super also das aufmachen gegen
südkirchen auch machen ging echt aber
daraus
diese chance gegen aids sind ohne pause
aber okay wir starten mit einem mini
matt fixing powder es ist translucent
zum make ups hätten ich benutze erst
seit kurzem wirklich bruder zum setzen
weil ich das früher nicht so ganz
geklappt hat muss aber sagen das macht
sind das einzige problem ist dass man
dadurch so ein bisschen mehr fältchen
hat wenn man so matt ist können wir
darüber sprechen also wirklich ein süßes
die in teils sehr weihnachtlich 8,5 naja
gut 1 euro 50 also ich hab es nicht
geöffnet ich werde die verlosungs
packung packen weil ich viele habe wie
sieht's ja ich hab's ja nicht aufgemacht
müssen komisch wenn ich euch was zum
verlosen schicker und das irgendwie
diese dings nicht hat aber es hat kein
schutz der gleichen nummer zwei moment
lipstick skandal
[Musik]
es sind zwei essens mini lipstick ich
dachte gerade das ist definiert und dann
dachte ich so was für den
weihnachtlichen duft haben sie benutzt
das riecht nicht guckt euch mal diese
spitze an
lustigerweise sieht sehr schlimm aus
aber riecht nicht so schlimm wieder
andere zeigt euch mal was da drauf ist
sieht aus wie schimmel uns bei dir werde
ich weder ausprobieren noch verlosen
irgendwie machen sie mir ein ganz
komisches bauchgefühl
dieses müsse sich bewegen also ganz klar
kostet 25 euro
matip sticks 3,8 gramm machen wir mal
zwei euro für diese lipstick halten tun
sie halt nicht so gut
diese nummer drei ein türchen nummer 3
befindet sich eine pinzette
das kommt dann sind mini mini compact
power lipstick suisse ist alles so ein
bisschen für die reisetasche ich habe
genug haare ich konnte meinen arm hand
testen und schön hartes zu drücken ein
euro fällig der kleinen pinzette dk was
man ganz groß meine hände so richtig
waschen gehen wohl überlegt drauf zu
machen aber ich will jetzt ehrlich
gesagt nicht mit weihnachtlichen
fingernägeln rumlaufen mail toll ist
wird mein gott leute bevor ich es
vergesse wir im bett noch ein
adventskalender rausgehauen den habe ich
natürlich bestellt ich sage einmal 50
cent ok 50 cent geben wir euch zum
verlosen die verlosung wird
wahrscheinlich sehr viel essen es
zwischen 85 das gros
oh mein gott das ist ja ich kann dafür
ich kann dafür gebe ich mein preis sagen
das ist das ist und dass made in poland
essen produziert ja sonst kein make-up
deswegen wird das von kosova produziert
ein neuer skandal wird aufgedeckt kost
nova hoss nova marken kosova beauty was
macht das nova beauty essens patrice
laufkurs nova gmbh ist das unternehmen
hinter den starken kosmetikmarken wie
essens patrice und läuft die haben diese
drei firmen um drei verschiedene gefühle
zu verkaufen essens ist die marke die
sich so ein junger leute wenden soll
immer die neuesten top trends cut
recession that make up serious about
people and the planet patrice fand ich
früher auch geholt ich glaube genau
wegen diesem liepelt planet und leif
brandt community college women gmbh
hannover ist ein familienunternehmen mit
unseren starken marken wie essens
kathrin lauf haben wir neue maßstäbe auf
dem internationalen koppers mid bank
wird diesen erfolg verdanken wir eine
ganze reihe von sind stolz nach so
vielen jahren rein in das schlanke
organisation wenig bürokratie
auszeichnet ja ja ganz toll und
innovativ also diese geschenkanhänger
die zähle ich jetzt nicht als preis das
ist wie so ein extra türchen nummer 6
und da
aussagen die produkte sind wirklich
unschuldig ich bin jetzt nicht die
zielgruppe die sie erreichen wollt
überbezahlte influenza mit zu viel zeit
aber sind synthetik könnte ich mir gut
führen ziele etc vorstellen oder um sich
im ohr zu kratzen zu finden sind sage
ich immer ja irgendwo selbständig ein
bild malen kann man sie immer gebrauchen
eur 29 die preise sind echt sind die
preise die man als teenager hat so eine
29 x 7
den braucht man wirklich denn ein
kajalstift die es geht ja immer so
schnell alle in einem weihnachtlichen
adventskalenders ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt ein kajalstift geben
da gibt es andere sachen aber der ist
gut denn schon früher benutzt essens
kanalstück lasst uns mal über den preis
schrecken ein
eur hinter türchen nummer acht verbirgt
sich eine handcreme mit einem schmalen
grat design ist schön größe sushi 50
milliliter kosten drei euro rissen 12
das ist
hier 50 cent die verlose ich die ist für
euch weil ich so ein gutes herz hat
bekommt wird diese handcreme dann mir
später ich ändern
9 ist meine lieblingszahl deswegen
bittet sie was richtig ist
hefti nach nail polish hier finden wir
wieder dass ein könig schwan design mini
metallic nadel hat schon wieder eine
kleine größe 1 eur 55 ein liter kostet
19 cent wir haben hier fünf also ein
euro im praktisch in die verlosung rhein
main
den bekommt ihr mal nicht auf eine
originalgröße mascara soir eur 79 die
bewertungen für die mascara es
eigentlich durchweg positiv also für 270
hatte hier ein tolles produkt aber
mittlerweile geht es mir wirklich nicht
mehr um die produkte so richtig da drin
also ja aber er ich habe langsam das
gefühl dass wir nicht so einen guten
deal gemacht haben wenn ich das sagen
könnte nochmal wir erinnern uns was
kostenloser gesagt
ist die marke nummer eins in europa und
das wurde produziert prc holz republik
china ich mit euch das nicht zur
verlosung geben weil ich das unbedingt
selbst behalten möchte so ein blödes
schon wieder cool ist dafür berechnen
wir kein cent weil wenn das in der
volksrepublik china produziert wurde
dann hat sie das vielleicht zwei cent
pro den gekostet ok ums pferd zu machen
zehn cent türchen nummer 12 damit sind
wir in der halbzeit angekommen
changing mensch sind wir dann wieder bei
dem slime angekommen lippenbalsam mit
farbwechsel mit vitamin e und süßes
mandelöl denn die lippen in einem
frischen pink einfärbt also sieht so aus
und das wird dann anscheinend pink kommt
natürlich in verlosung plus 2 euro
29 das ist fast so viel koste wie das
kann aber bestimmt ist es der trick von
essens erstmal die erwartung bisschen
runterschrauben und jetzt überraschen
jetzt kommt die zweite hälfte gegen
18.20 ich suche die 13 und die ski an
der seitlich das ist einfach nur deko
wird dadurch
das ist ja diese party queen mit dem
preis hier ledigen euro 99 ja mensch
zwei euro 99 das ist ja ein ding du aber
auch gleich ausprobiert ich bin heute
einfach mal so verrückt da kenne ich
auch nix macht das richtig gerne wenn
karneval der kulturen ist wo das
festival la paloma oder so meine jetzt
mit corinna gehe das nicht
holt man sich die partie nach hause was
ist das mit menschen und glitzersteinen
warum stehen wieder so sehr darauf
ganz ehrlich ich würde am liebsten jeden
tag so rumlaufen dann wäre man mal krass
sind einfach war dass du dein ding wäre
schminkt sich jeden tag und dann kriegst
du die am ende steine aufs gesicht
du siehst immer aus wie eine schöne 11
ok ok dankeschön für diesen tollen
anspitzer aber ganz ehrlich also ein an
spitze erreicht also wenn man sich
einmal make up ich bin so ein konsum
opfers ist unglaublich sehr schön sehr
praktisch toll super toll super toll
euro kostet der anspitzer
[Musik]
ich gucke werden die ja es ist das mini
high class top coat na ja es braucht man
doch immer gern eigentlich ganz schön
wenn man sich gar nicht so gerne die
fingernägel bunt lackiert dass man
einfach nur ein bisschen glänzenden top
gut drauf macht ich finde dann wirken
einfach nie gepflegt und tut mir dieser
information was ihr möchtet 25 cent pro
milliliter das ding hat fünf also ein
euro in rund 20 dazu das kommt in die
verluste damit ihr den auch noch spaß
bitte mach keine wortspiele styler
wirklich süß mit einem kleinen pinsel
und zwei farben hell dunkler sich aber
bitte liebe schminkt anfänger macht
nicht den fehler und macht aus euren
augenbrauen so zwei blöcke versucht so
ein bisschen auch mal eine lücke
dazwischen zu lassen so ein bisschen das
natürlich aussehen zu lassen das wird
verlost der großteil 42 also immer sagen
ich habe irgendwie mehr erwartet und
meidling grc keine haargummis bender
das ist im anhang gummi das ist ein
stück elastischer stopfe ich meine
natürlich das ist total blind taub
das ist für die lippen das wird einfach
meine neue existenz ich werde einfach so
eine elfe auf youtube ich liebe den
einzige was mir gerade ein bisschen nach
sind diese glitzer partikel am und wie
viele werde ich jetzt davon essen also
vergleichsweise kosten die produkte zwei
euro deswegen mache ich bloß zwei euro
mit diesem tollen glitter lippen top
bist du die schneekönige man zubehör
also ich sehe das eher 19
riesen türchen make up remover teil make
up remover toll fand ich sehr empfehlen
ich benutze welche ja das ist auch aus
microfaser weil jetzt nicht die höchste
qualität das kann ich sehr schneller
kennen
aber es ist sehr praktisch und muss das
auch nur nass machen wünscht sich damit
das make up vom gesicht und kann das
einfach so in die waschmaschine
schmeißen wenn man mehrere hat dann
braucht man halt wirklich keine
wattepads benutzen also danach trotzdem
noch das hand gesicht waschen aber das
grobe erste mega kriegt man damit
wunderbar weg kreuzt rooney china
produziert zum sind komisch es ist eine
sehr sehr schlechte qualität ich glaube
ich werde das eher fürs waschbecken zum
putzen benutzen als mein gesicht es tut
mir leid volksrepublik china
da bei 50 cent wir befinden uns nun auf
der zielgeraden türchen nummer eine
weihnachtliche formen
also es ist ein glänzender mini
nagellack ich finde glänzenden farben
zurzeit sehr schön ist ein
weihnachtliches roth ich würde sagen ja
ich dachte gerade er das ist so vielen
sommer mehr passt aber es hat schon
dieses ganz typische weihnachtliche rot
dam wurde so bisschen zu viel pink mit
drin ist aber ja ich meine das ist jetzt
schon jetzt schon der dritten nagellack
der kompakt auf jeden fall keinen
einzigen cent weil das ist schon wieder
so ein produkt das kostet in der
massenabfertigung kostet das wirklich
weiß ich zehn cent pro stück oder so das
ist jetzt nicht erwähnenswert mag aber
die schrift vorne nur das buch fühlt
sich an wie so wie wenn man diesen neuen
wasserkocher holt und eine
bedienungsanleitung dazu kommt also ab
und so gibt so ein spruch wenn es ist
aber schon dass nena meine motivation
ist gerade so gedroppt highlighter stick
die jungen leute würden auch schon
highlight werde ich natürlich nicht
anfassen sondern verlosen ich würde
diese mini größe mit 1 euro schätzen
weil das 1,8 gramm sind so kommen wir
zum nächsten tor mensch ich bin schon
gespannt
ich finde das macht keinen sinn weil
sowas es so typisch sommer dass man sich
solche tattoos irgendwie um den fuß um
die hand und so macht wo soll man sich
im winter mit einem pullover das dahin
machen
ja okay okay du wirst was kommt das 24
türchen mit beschenkt uns essen sun
weiter eine mini highlighter bratschist
aber cool also ich hab wirklich genug
pinsel so große was auf meinen lippen
drauf was und jetzt fällt meint es
dieses scheint glitzert trockene haut
auf den lippen
ich will darüber nicht länger nachdenken
so zurück zu unserem wunderschönen
pinsel ich finde das tatsächlich sehr
gut mit diesen stern gewöhnt hier drin
plus 1 euro 15 gekommen bei einem
gesamtwert 28 euro und 19 cent der
einkaufswert ist ja noch mal ein ganz
anderer und deswegen muss ich sagen ich
bin schon doch enttäuscht doch auf jeden
fall ich bin enttäuscht mit diesem
adventskalender schwind gerade bei
europas nummer eins hätte man das
bisschen so machen können dass sich das
auch lohnt diesen zu kaufen dafür
bekommt man ja aber auch rein nagellack
wo man vielleicht die eine farbe schon
hat oder einen schimmer liegen
lebensstil wo man nicht weiß ob es
wirklich ist ich würde es auf jeden fall
positiv hervorheben dass das alles sehr
schön aufgemacht ist das ist alles
diesen weihnachtlichen look hat aber am
ende ist es doch schon ganz schön abzock
gerade mit solchen produkten dazwischen
wo man wirklich nur dieses eine blatt
mit ein paar stücken drauf was
wahrscheinlich gar nichts gekostet hat
die muss man sagen es hat jetzt nicht
versucht einen tollen adventskalender
raus zu bringen sondern essens hat ein
weg versucht mit diesem ganzen
adventskalender hey das ist schon okay
aber als verbraucher fühlt es sich so an
als ob man so ein bisher in wendisch
gezogen wurde
mein fazit ist auf jeden fall daumen
runter dieser kalender nicht werk le
unterm strich scheiße dafür stehe ich
mit meinem namen ich hab euch lisa
adventskalender test gefallen in dem so
ist dann zeigt es mir unbedingt mit
einem daumen nach oben und schreibt doch
vielleicht 1 kommentar was für ein
adventskalender ich noch testen soll
bis euch gerade so geht solche
interaktionen helfen wie immer
eigentlich ganz gut main kanal zu pushen
und damit ihnen auch andere leute
entdecken
bis dann bis zum nächsten mal glitzer
einhorn wanne
[Musik]